[Music]
all right so let's really focus on what
you've done with the Michaela school
that you started in 2014 there was a lot
in in the research that I was doing
about discipline really before you even
get to education so you guys do a
bootcamp before you get to teaching them
anything you're actually teaching them
some things P early about discipline and
and sort of how to live how to behave
yeah yeah and that's because we believe
you haven't taught them how to behave
then you can't give them a detention for
it because they don't know how and the
reason why they don't know how is
because we know that elsewhere they
haven't necessarily been taught they
haven't necessarily learned it at home
they certainly want to learn it at other
schools and that's because our
expectations are really high and so we
teach them we have silence in the
corridors for instance so that's
something people come and they say why
do you have to be so extreme I'll tell
you why you had to be so extreme because
otherwise you've got kids fighting in
the corridors bashing each other's heads
against the wall some schools where
teachers are scared to walk through the
corridors because it's such mayhem you
have silence everybody just moves really
quickly to their lessons you've got
change over that takes maybe a minute
and a half children aren't losing loads
of time from their lessons I we say 59
minutes out of every 60 minutes in the
lesson you've got it at Makayla and
we're trying to catch them up you know a
lot of our kids come to us for the
reading age of a five-year-old
six-year-old when they are 11 years old
in fact I mean some of them aren't like
that some of them are Oxbridge material
and we'll go to oxford a Cambridge and
some of them need real help so that they
don't leave school illiterate and a
numeron 20% of the kids in Britain leave
school illiterate and innumerate right
20% one out of five kids now and that's
functionally so it looks like they can
read but they can't really read and this
is happening across the country and it's
become normal to expect that now none of
our kids going to be in that position
because we teach them so and we teach
them in an environment where the
children are able to respect their
teachers they love their teachers they
thanked them for their lessons at the
end of their lessons they say good
morning and good afternoon and so on and
things that you would never imagine you
know inner-city kids you you you know if
you have an idea
in your head if what need to see kids
are like you imagine the boys walking
with their with the trousers down here
in the kind of way and and and girls
dressing in a way that isn't appropriate
at our school none of that exists so you
do have a dress code right well they
have a uniform the uniform and that's
normal in Britain everybody has a
uniform yeah but the thing is we
actually stick to the uniform so you go
elsewhere there the ties are down
the shirts are untagged they look like a
mess they walk like a gangster I'm
always saying to the kids I mean if they
start if they ever start barking like
that I say you look like a gangster you
need to stop that right and they get it
they say yeah yeah I miss yeah yeah I
get it I get it and then they start
doing it because we talk about getting
to the best universities we want you to
get the Ivy League universities to get
to Russell Group universities in Britain
and we want you to have you know you aim
for the moon you land amongst the stars
that's why we think right and so they're
all really ambitious and they're all
working hard why anyone would be against
this as a concept okay I don't know so
when you hear pushback against that I
guess it's that people think it's like
presumptuous or something to imply that
their parents can't do it even if often
the parents are failing or or the
parents just have to work too hard and
they don't have time to do the things
that you're doing and I think then
people think there's a racial element to
that so if you even address that I
actually have a problem with it itself
they don't like the idea of us being in
authority mmm they don't like they think
being in authority means that we must be
Nazis I've been called not a Nazi many a
time which is a bit ironic when you
think that what the Nazis would have
done to somebody like me but exactly so
and they don't like the idea of us being
in authority and us being in charge so
one we're really key on discipline but -
we want the discipline so that we can
teach them properly and this is where
you're referring to what you said yes
sir I was watching you at the Oxford
Union and you said about how kids need
to be taught properly and I was and
you've said they need to be taught
critical thinking and take me to task
yeah yeah yeah the thing is is that you
can't teach critical thinking right peep
are critical in their thinking or
independently minded or inquisitive when
they know lots about something and it's
only by knowing lots it's like a 10,000
hour thing you know you got Malcolm
Gladwell you got you know Steve Jobs you
got the Beatles you spend a lot of time
doing something you will get really good
at it and then you'll be able to break
the rules uh-huh
but if you're trying to break the rules
right right away when you don't know
anything then you end up with kids and
this is it the public don't realize just
how bad things are where kids don't know
where Paris is you know kids don't know
in Britain who Winston Churchill is you
know they genuinely they have no idea
and that's because nobody's taught them
because people are anti knowledge so the
grandfather to like the whole knowledge
movement is is Edie Hirsch and he's an
American his most recent book is why
knowledge matters which I would
encourage all of your viewers to read
you know education is the most important
thing in any country right and and
that's one of reasons I'm so pleased to
be talking to you because people need to
realize you know you you you can have
all your arguments about free speech and
about about I don't know guns and about
whatever it is you want but if the
schools are not teaching children
properly then that is the end of any
country right and I am desperately
trying to shout as much as I can to tell
people too that we need to do something
and we are doing something I mean we're
doing something and other people we're
not the only ones you know there are
other people who are doing things we
named mckaela mckaela after a woman who
died of cancer who I used to work with
and she in her own classroom used to do
exactly this and there are teachers all
over America and all over Britain doing
this in their own classrooms we need we
need it to be more than that we need
entire school districts you know we need
people to get this point and when you
said about teaching critical thinking
it's a romantic view that comes from
Rousseau so 18th century philosopher
Rousseau and he said you know man is
born free but everywhere in Chains this
whole idea of you education makes you
less
free this is what the the progressives
think and actually self-control brings
you freedom right it's counterintuitive
but actually order and structure make
you free they allow you to pursue all
those avenues of knowledge basically
because you have a sort of Center
exactly if you learn lots about
something then you're able to apply that
knowledge in different ways so I mean as
an example um you know if you take a
math question that a primary school kid
might be given you know John has 8 cents
at the end of the day it's one quarter
of what he had at the beginning of the
day how much money did he spend during
the day now I think I can do it and I
don't I think you can - I'm terrible at
math but I do I think you can do it is
because you got short-term memory and
long-term memory and you've got a whole
bunch of math facts in your long-term
memory that you're able to draw out
you're able to go quarter know there's 4
of those in a hole and then you're able
to go 4 times 8 because I know my 4
times table and then I can do
subtraction so I can take it to 24 yeah
right now if you're 7 years old however
if you have to hold all those facts in
your working memory working memory can't
do it you have got to drill and practice
those a time table facts for instance
and put them into your long-term memory
and put those fractions into your
long-term memory so that when somebody
gives you something more complex you can
go bam bam bam and bring it out and then
you've got the answer sadly what happens
is people say now what we need to do is
teach some complex problem-solving let's
give them that mm-hmm
first you got to break it down what are
the bits underneath that you've got to
build up from and that stuff is a bit
boring yeah and because it's boring and
isn't very romantic this ruse I was
talking about for soso Rousseau this
idea with you you you you bring it out
of the child right so they they have
this phrase which says you know the mind
is not a vessel to be filled but a spark
to be ignited it all sounds really
exciting and thrilling right and that's
the thing it's so seductive it pulls
everybody in but the reality is that
actually what you need is a whole lot of
facts and you're in your memory
there that you can then go boom boom
boom and apply now that doesn't mean
that you're just a parrot and you just
end up learning a whole load of facts
which you then can just you know
regurgitate you need to apply them and
you need to give children the chance to
apply them and have a class discussion
and we do paired work and so on often in
more progressive places they'll do group
work
they'll put five kids four kids around
the table and they do group work and
then what happens is the teacher moves
amongst them as a facilitator of
learning as opposed to the teacher who's
driving the bus I always say the teacher
needs to sit in the bus and drive and
the kids get on the bus with you and go
the more progressive way you're there
just keeping them on task you do that
let me come and see you you do that but
they don't learn very much and then they
don't succeed and then we say it's
because they were black it's because
they were poor what we need to do is
give them welfare and then they'll be
okay because that will make them equal
and my point is no fix the education
system give them an education and then
they'll make themselves equal gosh this
reminds me of
so I mentioned I'm not that good at math
and I remember the day I haven't thought
about this in probably 15 maybe
literally maybe 20 years I remember
being in sixth or seventh grade and we
were doing division for the first time
yes and I remember the teacher gave us
we had a quiz or something and I was
able to do it in my head and I so she
they had you know the the equation and I
just wrote the answer and she gave me AI
failed or I got a zero or something even
though I had all the answers right she
said you didn't show your work and I and
I remember saying her but I got all the
answers right and she said no no I need
to see how you do work now I didn't know
how to do it that way but somehow I was
able to do it in my head and I remember
thinking that if that was all necessary
to show the work that at some point I
would get to a place where I would have
to do it but somehow I had figured out
my little trick first but because of the
way she kind of just failed me for it it
completely turned me off man I really
haven't thought of that in probably 20
years or something that's this total
sidebar altogether but I guess just to
show that we all we all kind of learned
differently and you need teachers that
can kind of embrace the way you do it a
little bit rather than just jam it down
your throat
yeah well you use which is probably a
little bit
the progressive thing that you don't
like in a way yeah what I would say is
you remember that particular incident
and think that's all it was but I
guarantee you that had you been taught
properly in that classroom you would
have known her methods yeah you would
have known what to write down you didn't
know what to write down cuz there was
too much chaos in the classroom you
weren't listening
you were busy talking to your friend
because she let you talk because she
didn't have high enough standards of
behavior and so you there yeah well and
that's it because this is just standard
this is just what happens in all
classrooms and then people think you
know it's mean to make kids behave and
after a while the thing is is that
remember there's more of them than there
is of us right so we're not actually
making them do anything they want to
behave we're just creating an
environment where they're able to do it
right that's all now there's there's the
there's the 10% there's the 10% on the
outskirts that the detentions I saw and
keep them in line right but the vast
majority you need that tipping point
the vast majority buy into what we do
and if you come visit our school the
kids will say to you yeah it's super
strict and yeah we get the tensions but
you know what I get a great education
yeah and that's what I want because I
want the opportunity to be able to
change my stars and if you believe that
if you believe in equality of
opportunity which sadly I think too many
people in education don't believe in
equality of opportunity if you do then
you want to provide an environment where
they're going to be able to do that and
and and that's what we do and and I and
I really hope those teachers who come
and visit us they're able to take from
that and and and and do something in
their schools yeah well first off I told
you before we started I'm gonna be in
the UK with Jordan beaters and put a
couple stops so I will do everything I
can to stop by and maybe I can get
Jordan to swing by wow yeah daughter is
Mikayla by the way so they're really
deep powerful powerful what about the
type of kids you've mentioned that
there's some diversity and the type of
kids that are coming and how do you guys
decide who actually can can cut it and
can afford it and other you know all of
that well it's not up to us who comes to
us it's the local council that kind of
send kids to us so we gotta they decide
well it's a lottery and people apply and
then they get picked out of a hat
literally and then and then they come
some of the people you know some of the
kids would end up with us didn't even
necessarily want to be with us they just
end up being pushed towards us because
that's the way the system goes I mean
frankly I don't even understand the
system but we get a bunch of kids we got
120 kids in every year so it's a pure
lottery to get to the school yeah and
basically if they don't win the lottery
so to speak they're just going to the
public school because at that point most
likely the parents can't afford a
private school right yeah yeah no
definitely the parents can't afford a
private school but there's no I mean you
talk about it as if we're different I
mean like we're just another school
there's loads of schools like us in that
sense around I mean we are a free school
but yeah it doesn't it's not like we're
the free school and then there's the
local public school there's loads
there's lots of schools and and parents
will choose us if they want to and as I
say sometimes we end up with with with
kids because the system is such that you
have to choose your top five schools and
you know if you chosen us fifth you
probably don't want to be with us but in
the name of fairness as the people
who've chosen as fifth have just as much
of a chance getting it and as the people
Jackson got very American there I grew
up in Canada so but yeah so people who
don't want to come to us come to us and
people who do really want to come to us
come to us and look you know I call
myself the dragon lady and I say you
know what I'm not gonna change and if
you're happy to put up with me these are
the rules and this is what we do so if
we hear your phone or if we see your
phone we'll take it and we will keep it
for up to 16 weeks and that's the way
that it is
you know these smart phones are killing
kids I wanted to get there yeah yeah
what do you make of that because it's a
it's a disaster and in 20 years people
are gonna know you know when I say it
now people say oh you're being extreme
you know some schools they actually have
these phones out in lessons lots of
schools they have them out in corridors
and in the yard and so on
we have them banned completely and I'm
even trying to get parents to take them
away at home we know we sell brick
phones so your phone that you can't
access the Internet
so that trouble you try and encourage
parents give them that you want to keep
in touch with a kid fine I understand
but you don't need to give them a
smartphone that accesses the Internet
you know Steve Jobs Bill Gates all of
those big guys in nightie they don't
give their children phones until they're
15 they keep them away when Steve Jobs
in 2010 and the iPad came out and he was
interviewed and they said what did you
think about what does he what do your
kids think about the iPad and he said I
don't know I wouldn't give my kids the
iPad he they they protect their children
meanwhile our parents have no idea
they're there saving up for months but
give their kids this Christmas present
and it's it's it's like giving them
heroin I say it's like playing Russian
roulette you know who you give anybody
access to your child on this phone right
any weirdo out there knows who your
child lives knows where how they go to
school knows where they go to school
knows who their friends are they get in
I'm in I I don't understand
well the reason why people do this is
because they don't know and they don't
think about the dangers not just with
random people but also lovely girls who
get involved with the bad boys at school
bad boys who might be criminals
elsewhere etc and they they quite like
them and they wouldn't otherwise known
them but oh you maybe he's gonna add me
on snapchat whoa you know and this is
the kind of it's terrible what about
just for attention spans because I would
imagine you're dealing with a lot of
that for young people right now it's not
supposed to have snapchat as you just
said exactly so you know before when
they used to watch you know Dallas and
dynasty and so on at least there was a
narrative arc that went like this and it
told a story and then something bad
happened and then it gets resolved and
so on never gonna happen anymore
you got like 20 second I went to the
hairdresser's look at this man's bald
head and there's a little ditty that's
what they're watching right right it's
terrible so smartphones are a huge
problem for the inner city and but the
biggest problem I would say our
progressive teaching methods that have
infiltrated our schools and sadly this
kind of Russo an idea that you're
drawing something out of the child as
opposed to putting something in and the
way in which over the last 50 years we
have turned
away from knowledge as being really
important this hits of course the most
vulnerable so working-class kids in our
country you know that tends to be a
black thing in this country in our
country you know in in Britain it will
be black kids but it'll also be white
working-class kids it'll be a variety of
different kids who get hit by this
because if you are from a richer
background your parents you know you sit
around the dinner table at night and you
have dinner and you talk about the
politics of the day and you learn about
different countries and and science and
all sorts of things just through talking
to your parents and to your parents
friends and your uncle and your aunt and
so on with kids whose parents are not
well educated they don't get that at
home so they're depending entirely on
the school to give them what they need
to be able to succeed and sadly because
schools are convinced about this idea of
this romance around thinking critically
and and and that's not to say we don't
want to thinking critically we do yeah
but you need to give them lots of stuff
to get them to that point right so when
I said that at Oxford Union about
teaching critical thinking it's not that
you don't believe in critical thinking
of course it's that you really that's
not that's not something to teach at
least at first it's that you have to
give them all the the breadth of
knowledge first and then they will learn
how to critically think about all the
claims issues fair enough I like to see
criticism and and it's it's something
that we're just you're having to fight
all over the place and and it's that
idea of giving them that equality of
opportunity which is what I can't I keep
coming back to because many instances
where this doesn't work I mean have
there been kids that come through and
just for whatever reason this this
concept that you've built that you're
instilling in all these other students
it just does not work for them either
because of something about them or the
family or I've had to exclude a few
children for knives you know that is
something in the inner-city that's a
problem you know when we talk about
inner-city you know we've got kids
showing up you know young men showing up
on bikes with masks carrying knives
waiting to meet some of our kids you
know this this is the inner city so
there are some of those issues that can
take over you know
but but that doesn't mean that it hasn't
worked it always works the kids always
learn more than they've ever learned
anywhere else the kids always are
stunned by their own intelligence and
what is possible because we show that to
them and it's um you know and what kind
of breaks my heart is that even those
who are conservative so you ever I watch
all your programs and you have all these
great people to come on but nobody ever
talks about education you Larry elder
for instance who I love and I think he's
brilliant yeah you know he talks about
all these things play in the black
community and he has all this stats that
he always comes out with and there's
that thing where he takes you apart you
know he's not my real moments yeah yeah
but what but what he doesn't do he took
some absent fathers she talks about
crime talks about drugs and so on but
they never talk about education and the
thing is education that's not black
people's fault right that isn't that
that is where the state right and the
state needs to be held to account for
this because we spend in Britain 80
billion pounds a year on the state
education system and yet we are failing
all of our kids and that isn't right we
and and Larry elder and all of these
people who talk they need to be able to
say no wait a minute there's something
going wrong at a very low level because
you can you can talk all you want about
personal responsibility but if you
haven't got an education it's very hard
to make anything of your life so is the
problem then that in at least in the
American context the answer always is
throw more money at it so it's not the
real answer which obviously we've spent
45 minutes talking about which is Hawaii
and how you have to clean up these
schools but the easy answer is always
throw more money at it if they just need
more money you know you always hear
these things well they don't have enough
pencils and they don't have enough you
know other supplies and notebooks and
things and people don't take the next
step which would be the critical
thinking step of the whole thing not
about money you could throw money at
anything yeah the irony is they all go
on about critical thinking they're not
doing any critical thinking you know if
only they would but um I I wish we'll
look I mean the the left really refused
they refused to recognize there's even a
problem the right will recognize that
there's a problem but they don't talk
about it so so I'm saying about the
people who you interview and so on I
just wish more people would say actually
the solution is in education because it
really is
the the black community for instance you
know would would transform if they were
given the opportunity to have a great
education and and that's not to say that
all the things that Larry Alda talks
about about absent fathers and so on
aren't a problem right I mean they are
absolutely but it's really important to
call them out on it and it's really
important to call out you see and this
is where I would disagree you know I
consider myself a conservative and a
black conservative but I would disagree
with some of the black conservatives out
there who refused to recognize racism as
a problem at all you know they kind of
just dismiss it and I would say no it is
a big problem and the reason it's a big
problem is because the left in so many
ways are racist you know when they want
to own us and they want to tell us how
we can vote and they want to tell us how
we can think that is racism and when
they refuse to recognize what works in
education that's gonna help poor kids
black kids you know white working-class
kids in Britain when they refuse to look
at that well that's racist and I'd say
it's racist against the white
working-class the way the white
working-class are spoken about in
Britain is the way that sometimes black
the black communities have spoken about
in America which is like there's some
kind of different they're aliens or well
you know that's just the way they are no
that's not the way they are actually if
you give them the opportunity but you
all want to sit around dinner parties
and talk about how kind you are and how
great you are cuz your virtue signalling
and voting on the left you know and I
just wish I suppose that there were more
conservatives who were speaking out
about this and saying something yeah I
guess there's a weird reflex for them
where they've been called racist for so
long even though often they are
minorities yeah yeah where they don't
want I see this I definitely see this
yeah where they don't want to use the
same tactic so what you just said right
there is such a flip on the way we think
of racism I tend to agree with that line
of thinking obviously yeah the people
that are screaming about racism are all
the time now are the people who are who
are racist they really are and I don't
necessary I don't say that lightly
because I don't like calling people Isis
but they're the ones were demanding and
I look at everyone based on race and
sexuality in the rest of this now we
have to call it out but I think there's
a hesitancy from at least from sort of
where I sit cuz I don't want to become
what
they became but no but I know I know
you're right at the at the core of this
look I understand you don't want to say
everything is racist but when there is
real racism you need to point it out and
you know the fact is that the fact is
that if we don't call it out all of
these kids are going to keep failing
right what we don't realize is that all
these kids are going through school and
are being taught to make sure that
they're going off and voting on the left
that's how it is like that that is that
that's how everyone thinks like it's
it's so standard in the education you
know system to think on the left that
the few conservative teachers that there
are out there they're quiet they never
say anything because they're terrified
right there is no balance of thought and
and and that's really scary I think and
for the future of our countries we we
need people to talk to each other the
stuff that you're always talking about
about talking to each other and sharing
ideas and thinking about how the other
the other side thinks and and I worry
that we don't we don't do enough of that
we don't do enough of it at school
that's for sure and then those kids turn
into adults eventually don't they and
then and then we just you know well I
don't and then they're really pissed at
the system that they believes failed
them and then they just perpetuate that
through the next generation too and then
eventually that's unsustainable actually
because then you have enough people that
are turning against the system that's
failed them yes it's because no one
stood up and did what you're doing but
it's interesting because this is where a
good old American classical liberal and
I know you guys at least in the UK have
a better understanding of what classical
liberalism I think that we do here we
talk about this a little bit before that
yeah and I'm getting muddled and mangled
and all that but this is a place where
to me where the government should be
involved I'm all for using tax dollars
yeah to do the things you're talking
about where some might think there are
plenty of people that are American
conservatives at least that want to just
cut funding from all of these things and
endlessly cut funny as I said I'm not
for throwing money at them just because
let that's just the
the answer but yeah let's figure out how
do we wisely use money to empower these
teachers and that sounds like that's
exactly what you're doing well exactly
it's you know it's the power of bad
ideas at the moment that over the last
50 years you know 60 70 years ago the
schools that were out there were were
more like our school now it's just that
things have changed so radically where
knowledge has been sidelined it's all
about skills people talk about skills
and drawing it out of the child like I
was saying and we've we've lost we've
lost the purpose of Education and we've
lost you know the ideas that we have
about perseverance even when it's
difficult especially when it's difficult
personal responsibility you know if you
didn't bring in your homework and you
are responsible for that
whereas elsewhere they'll say oh well
it's not your fault you come from a
difficult family difficult background
we're gonna give you an excuse and if
you're constantly being given those
excuses and if later on getting into
university there are quotas and if
you're likely to get in because you're
black or you're you know there's they're
there things allow you
oh I took that box I took that box I'm
gonna be able to get in with a lower
score then you stopped setting those
standards for yourself right and then we
do we eventually degrade the whole
system because if you let someone in at
a lower level and then also let them get
a job at a lower level or get into grad
school at a lower level and the job at a
lower level everything else yeah well
now whatever you've created as a
professional is a degraded version of
whatever that supposed to be that's
right that's right and and that is
what's happening sadly there's a whole
campaign at the moment in Britain for
this to happen with Oxford and Cambridge
University to to essentially allow kids
I mean it's just it's it's it's it's
really sad and what the reason why is
because they say hey look there aren't
that many black kids at Oxford and
Cambridge we need to fix this we do I
agree we need to fix it so we need to
fix the education system we need to fix
our schools and make sure that they're
given nothing polity of opportunity well
I'll tell you that day that I spent at
Oxford was such an absolute joy in
talking to so many kids just in the
streets and just and everybody was so
like excited
learn and yeah obviously they were
sympathetic to a lot of the things that
I talked about and and all that I'm
curious so I get it sort of on the
sciences and math and that you really
want to teach them the facts on this
stuff on things like history yeah well
are the facts in history no no there are
facts in history but I but I wonder now
these days where it seems like young
people are kind of into socialism or
young people are kind of into communism
or Marxism the rest of it have you found
that teaching history has become oddly I
was gonna say oddly political I mean it
of course it is political but oddly
politicized yeah so like Hitler for
instance has taught to death but say the
the atrocities of communism and so on
are not taught so much or even then so
rarely is so little is tort full stop
because they're not being taught
properly in the classroom because you
are facilitating learning and kids are
just teaching themselves I mean that I
can't stress how much of that is
actually going on so yes things are
politicized and children are not able to
access the kind of education that they
were able to access before and it's hard
because I'll say that and then people
will just deny that that's what's going
on but you can see by if you talk to
university kids at university and ask
them what do they know about the world
and so on
what do they think they'll tell you and
you'll see how much they've been taught
what they've been taught at school so
few of them have an understanding of
communism and what it is
and that's because they're not learning
it properly at school school is sadly
it's um it's I wish that there was more
diversity of thought amongst teachers so
one of the reasons why we watch a lot of
you the Rubin report is because I want
my staff to try and think outside the
box what I always say is I can predict
everything that you think about every
issue out there so if I know that you
definitely voted remain as opposed to
brexit with regard to the European Union
for us or if I know for sure that you
would vote for Corbin the the leader of
the Labour Party in Britain or
I know you know what you would have to
say about a whole variety of different
things even what newspaper you read if I
can make all those predictions there's
something wrong cuz you know with me I'm
conservative on some issues but I'm i'm
anti guns for instance i'm pro-choice
and program marriages all sorts of
things that i'm very much on the left on
there's other things that i'm more
conservative about you know and that's
because i'm a thinking person yeah yeah
classical liberal yeah those in many
ways hara one might say that you know
i'm yeah the point is i just want people
to think outside the box right and I
wish teachers would and that there was
more diversity of thought and there is
some diversity of thought but they have
to keep quiet because they're terrified
how do you ensure that you get the right
teachers well in a way it's its self
selecting so when they apply it they're
already people who are who are somewhat
thinking outside the box and then they
and then they come and I think being at
the school also changes their minds
about things they start to think
differently because they're seeing
what's possible people can't imagine
what's possible with inner-city kids
until they come to our school I have
visitors teachers who are visitors
they're nearly in tears they're saying
can't believe that these kids are so
nice so that's that's what we're trying
to do and the point but and it happens
here you know I've been to see so I said
Edie Hirsch you know some of the schools
where they use his materials and they
place knowledge at the heart of their
curriculum I've seen some of those
schools in the Bronx and in in in
various big Queens and so on and and
they're doing a great job - I just wish
more of it was happening and that we
could we could get a bigger platform to
talk about it because it's just so
important but people don't people don't
get that they don't get that starting to
get it you think so yeah I do I think
that's why these types of things are
working that's why you're half a world
away you know thousands of miles away
and you've shown this the conversations
that we're having here to your staff
yeah the amount of people that are
showing up to these live events amount
of people that are downloading these
podcasts and all that it's starting to
happen
hmm
yeah well I hope so I hope so I mean
there's there's so much to be had you
know I've known tens of thousands of
kids people often say why do I do what I
do because I've known tens of thousands
of kids who could have been so much more
right who could have been in a position
to change their stars and they weren't
able to because the state is spending so
much money on their education and isn't
able to provide them with a decent
education and that's really sad
all right now one more for you yeah I
want you to offer so I know that I have
a lot of young people obviously that
listen to the show high school sometimes
junior high school but college whatever
else just for the general young person
out there that's watching this that's in
a school that's not doing these things
that's trying to figure out how to learn
anything critically and get a good wide
breadth of knowledge but the situation
that they're in is not everything you've
offered here well what would you say to
them to just start doing it for
themselves you gotta take personal
responsibility so you can't be a victim
you know the whole victimhood thing is
just stoked all the time in schools and
and indulged you you got to think it
doesn't matter where I am great I
haven't had the best luck right I would
have loved to be able to go to that
local private school but you know what
so what I'm gonna I'm gonna sit out and
I'm gonna work and I'm gonna work really
hard and I'm gonna go to the library and
I'm gonna find the book so I'm gonna
teach myself if necessary and I've known
kids like this who have done this I've
known colleagues of mine and people who
I've known they just they they make it
their business to teach themselves what
they need to know and they need to know
that knowledge is at the heart of it you
need to know lots of stuff and then you
can manipulate that stuff and then you
can be intelligent with that stuff right
you can do it you can the thing is is
that it's rare that a 15 year old takes
that upon themselves to do it they are
by definition their exceptional most
kids need somebody to guide them and if
their parents aren't doing it then I
think the school certainly can do it
whether or not the school should there
are people will say well it's not fair
schools shouldn't have to do that the
parents should do that and it's true and
you know what if if welfare were not as
generous as it is and so on the parents
probably would have more agency and
self-determination of
themselves and the incredible catch-22
yeah they would take more responsibility
and they would do something and sadly
the state hits them in both ways right
because it gives them the heroine of
welfare and then it suppresses them by
not giving them a decent education and
then they sit around and they talk oh
and they say oh I'm a really good person
because I believe in giving people loads
of welfare and in having terrible
education I mean you know you punch
somebody on one side then you punch them
on the other side how on earth are they
meant to succeed right and the thing is
we spend a lot of money in tax to have a
state and I'm a classical liberal so I
believe in a small state but we do have
a state let's use it for what we can for
the good yeah but we're not doing that
and and that's what's that's what's
really scary and we we meet us all
believing in this idea of equality of
opportunity and that teaching children
self-control will make them free and and
and having an ordered environment where
children can learn will enable them to
learn lots of stuff so that they can
then be motivated to do something with
their lives because they will make
themselves free by by grabbing that
opportunity and and and and it's that
agency it's that sense of
self-determination that the
Conservatives people on the right right
leaning tend to believe in more as
opposed to mummy state coming in and
looking after it for you and taking care
of you because if that's what you aspire
to then what's the point of living right
but you know you have to teach dead
white men right like one of the big
problems we have is that they don't
wanna teach dead white men because
they're dead white men and that's a
problem right so they only want to teach
recently we had the situation where in
Manchester these students painted over a
mural of Kipling so red eared Kipling's
poem was up there and they painted it
over and put my Angelou's poem by Matt
my Angelou now I'm a great fan of Maya
Angelou I think she's brilliant but one
of the reasons why she's a great writer
is because she read a lot of Kipling
when she read a lot
in fact she said of Shakespeare that she
thought when she first read him that he
must have been a black woman because he
would have knelt he uh he had to be a
black woman to have understood the
plight of black women right because he
speaks to the human condition
right but he's a dead white male oh we
don't wanna teach him Oh Kipling he was
a racist we don't want to teach him but
at our school we've got them reciting
you know the poem if if you can keep
your head when all about you are losing
theirs and blaming it on you you know
but at the end of it at the end of it it
says the earth is yours and everything
that's in it and what's more you'll be a
man my son and that you'll be a man my
son but what about the women how can you
not be recognizing the women and in a
day and age where men can be women and
women can be men well he's obviously
speaking to me too yeah but there's our
rage oh no no he's only mentioned men
right it's the most beautiful poem our
children learn it off by heart
right but children elsewhere will never
have access to Kipling
now everyone needs has to be taught
about took the torch Shakespeare by law
you have to be taught Shakespeare but
the fact is we indulge in Shakespeare we
love Shakespeare because Shakespeare is
so beautiful and extraordinary
I'm just cuz he's a dead white guy well
does that mean that he didn't write
beautifully you know they're they're
just some beautiful I mean you know love
is not love which alters when it
alteration finds or bends with the
remover to remove it's also beautiful
and you want the children to be able to
access this and we teach them other
poems like Invictus which means an
unstoppable and when it was one of
Mandela's favorite poems and you know if
they say at the end I am the master of
my fate I am the captain of my soul and
all of our kids put their hands on here
when they say I am the master of my fate
and there's nearly 200 kids in the lunch
hole always belting this out and loving
it because they are the masters of their
fate and it's teaching the kids that and
inspiring them to make a difference with
their lives whatever their color as
opposed to saying oh well there's racism
and sexism in the world therefore you're
never going to be able to succeed
because then you just give up and don't
worry because there's welfare so you can
always just you know you can just take
the welfare instead of instead of making
something of your life you know and that
is
it is to kill a man when you kill his
self determination and you kill his his
agency and you kill his motivation to do
something with his life that is to kill
a man and that is what the left is doing
and and I say that's about that that is
racism I do and we should say it out
loud but we never do the conservatives
never call it and they should call it
what it is and you know well what can
you do you just got to keep going right
what a beautiful ending that's an ending
right there we're gonna clip that one
and do something with that cuz I'm just
probably well that this is what it's all
about this is everything that I'm trying
to do here you're talking about the the
roots and the foundation of all that and
you're doing it and I promise you I will
make it to the school one of them Oh
in the UK for that'd be great can I do a
little something can I give a little
talk maybe your that'd be lovely
we can do something this was really a
pleasure thank you so much I hung it in
and thanks to Douglas by the way so we
were used by Douglas Murray yes yes now
I know that anyone's a friend of Douglas
your for more on Katherine follow her on
Twitter it's at miss underscore Snuffy
[Music]